zum schluss kommen jetzt wirklich zu
einer sehr privaten frage da habe ich
auch lange überlegt ob ich die mit
reinnehmen etwas glatter als willkommen
beim neuen video die letzte folge
hiervon liegt schon einige zeit zurück
ich würde so schätzen eineinhalb monaten
hat zwei monate glaube ja der letzte
teil hab eigentlich ziemlich gut bei
euch an was mich so gewundert hatte ich
habe halt kurz gesungen und ist dann
wirklich mega viele kommentiert dass ich
ganz gut singen kann world to view okay
lass mich auf jeden fall habe ich mal
wieder mega bock auf dieses alex privat
also es geht halt so ja wieder ganz
viele fragen gestellt wirklich private
fragen bei mir werden die nicht so
einfach beantworten sondern wirklich
ehrlich beantwortet es gibt so viele
youtube sagen kompletten bullshit es
geht halt um sachen die ich glaube ich
wirklich ein bisschen interessiert und
nicht an langweilige fragen und
antworten video habt ihr wahrscheinlich
also wenn ihr die anderen folgen kennt
dann wisst ihr dann auch schon ich habe
diesmal wirklich unfassbar viele fragen
bekommen auf youtube und instagram über
1000 zusammen und wir versuchen jetzt
mal ein paar davon zu beantworten fangen
wir erst mal ganz locker lässt sich
anders wahr fragt die ja nie wie alpha
süchtig bist du auf einer skala von 1
bis 10
das ist wirklich eine sehr gute frage
also eigentlich bin ich nicht
eifersüchtig es gibt aber halt
situationen kennt ihr das so also ich
weiss nicht jetzt vielleicht ein club-
kennt jeder mensch ein versuch dich ein
versuch ist nicht eifersüchtig käufer
sucht es gibt also situationen da wird
einem so gesagt ach also seit das
irgendwie zusammen 8 dann musst du doch
nicht einfach süchtig sein dann längst
wie soja ich muss auch nicht
eifersüchtig sein deswegen ich vertraue
dir aber du bist trotzdem persönlich
kennt ihr das ja so würde ich das bei
mir jetzt mal definieren also es gibt
halt wirklich sachen da denke ich mir so
abkommen und dann ist es auch so aber es
gibt tolle sachen da ist es halt ich
würde jetzt sagen so sechs man kann es
ertragen
nächste frage ob ich auch schon wege oft
lesen und zwar erstmals wurdest du schon
mal gemobbt oder was da noch dahinter
stellen oder hast du wenig gemacht haben
dazu kann ich sagen also ich persönlich
so gemobbt wurde ich noch nie wirklich
also ich weiß nicht wie es ist gemobbt
zu werden kann euch nur sagen so ich
habe immer früher mit youtube angefangen
mit 14 890 abonnenten und das ist klar
das ist sehr viele leute belächeln die
das zugucken aber wird jetzt nicht
morgen aber so
eine andere hatte ich halte darüber
lustig gemacht auf ein bisschen mehr so
verlust gemacht aber gut muss man halt
darüber wechseln wenn man damit anfängt
gehört halt dazu zu der anfrage darauf
hinzu kam also ob ich schon mal weniger
mob habe ich persönlich hab halt also so
aktiv so von mir aus noch nie gemacht
aber was ihr euch sagen kann gut jetzt
würde ich das nie mehr wieder tun aber
man ist also sag ich mal in der fünften
klasse dann ist man halt in seiner
gruppe drin
und irgendwann fängt anhalt an gegen
irgendwas zu sagen und man macht halt in
dem alter so ist es halt beim menschen
dabei kippten dann sag ich mal wenn man
noch so jung ist man macht halt
automatisch ein bisschen mit aber ich
habe dann so im laufe der zeit ich würde
sagen der siebten oder achten klasse
gemerkt das ist das dümmste ist was auch
für 1 oder das schlimmste was es so für
einen mädchen oder jungen dem alter gibt
deswegen ich hasse es richtig ab normal
wenn irgendjemand jetzt in meinem alter
oder meinetwegen erneuten klasse wenn er
irgendwie gemobbt wir das einfach so
leute die irgendwann hof in der neuen
klasse sind einfach geistig noch nicht
reif die sind einfach auf dem niveau der
sechs- oder fünften klasse deswegen
unterstützt sein irgendwie drauf weiß
ich nicht kann ich nur sagen das ist
mega ton gegen mir zu machen ich mal
wurde ihr könnt natürlich meinungen über
ihre person haben ihr könnt auch
irgendwelche personen überhaupt nicht
mögen aber lasst ist irgendwas in einer
gruppe über personen zu sagen oder so es
gibt deutlich lassen das ziemlich nah an
sich heran und das ist finde ich
ziemlich scheiße ja kommen doch schon
zur nächsten frage mich wollte euch das
eigentlich noch gar nicht verraten aber
irgendwann gefragt ob in zukunft auch
mal was musikalisches oder eine parodie
von dir also ich mache das was ich jetzt
auf youtube schon ziemlich lange und ich
spiele schon ziemlich an gitarre also
von musik habe ich ein bisschen ahnung
und ich habe einfach mal bock auf was
komplett neues und ja ich hab da so ein
bisschen was in arbeite ich kennen wir
ziemlich gut der witz macht ich kenne
auch viele leute die im tonstudio uns
weiter haben also einfach mal gucken
ausprobieren und ich glaube da kommt was
vernünftiges bei rum und das kommt dann
halt denke ich meine monat über
eineinhalb monaten ich habe mega bock
einfach drauf und das hier richtig nice
hoffe ich wenn ich dann
ich will jetzt einfach mal ausprobieren
aber es ist genau ist das verrate ich
euch noch nicht deswegen seid gespannt
und das auch noch wirklich lustige frage
findest du deine videos gut fragt
leerung oder so auf jeden fall kann ich
dazu sagen ich finde meine videos soll
persönlich so wenn ich die schneider
will ich
dem einen video mal richtig zufrieden
mit dem einen auch überhaupt nicht war
bei mir ist es so weiß ich nicht ich
lasse aber trotzdem hoch und die videos
mit denen ich halt eigentlich gar nicht
so zufrieden bin die komme immer mega
gut bei euch an und die videos mit denen
ich sehr zufrieden bin so halt
durchschnittlich eigentlich hasse ich es
total mit eigenen videos zu gucken
deswegen kann ich wo ich sagen ich finde
sie zum teil schon scheiße aber solange
sie halt mega viele leute das heißt mega
viele leute also ok 143000 oder so
solange diese leute das heißt gut finden
mag ich so gerne und ich finds heftig
dass so viele leute dass schon ein
bisschen feiern deswegen danke auch mal
an dieser stelle ja die nächste frage
habe ich auch so 50 60 mal gelesen und
zwar hat willst du mit empfehlen eine
beziehung führen ich glaube ich hab's
auch irgendwo schon mal beantwortet auf
jeden fall gar nicht nur sagen man muss
halt immer gucken fassen jetzt wirklich
fan oder so und wenn man jetzt zum
beispiel eine person trifft von der man
eigentlich so richtig fan war und die
halb privat kennen lernt da kann man
sich selber nicht mehr das feld
bezeichnet finde ich und ich mein ich
kann mir auch nicht aussuchen ob du bist
in fällen von mir bekommst du für mich
gar nicht infrage das ist ja total dumm
wieso also ja okay zum schluss kommen
jetzt wirklich zu einer sehr privaten
frage da habe ich auch lange überlegt ob
ich die mit rein nehmen weil sie mich
ziemlich toll berührt hat und zwar fragt
die jasmin hat dort guckst du auch
manchmal die kiwis oder babys beauty
palace
natürlich ganz einfach mal sagen
soviel dazu ich habe mir überlegt marco
kofler 7000 lampen ist bestimmt drin
also ganz gut gefallen dass man doch
nach oben da und ansonsten geht es hier
oben weiter zu dem letzten video davon
also alex private nummer zwei war zu
können den ersten aufgalopp möglich
freuen wenn ihr jetzt formal feierte
lassen wir es in den kommentaren wissen
fragt mich weitere private unternehmen
kommentaren
wir sehen uns nächsten wir sehen uns
jetzt sonntag schon wieder sonntag gab
es nur einschalten nicht vergessen
ihr seid ganz cool also cool an sich